come on guys it's time
everyone can't see we're together happy
we're gonna be late to the Royal Wedding
let's go get married what I mean let's
get Bridget and Crystal married yeah oh
cause that would be weird if we got
married yeah wow
oh boy that was a crazy bachelor party
uh Cloud guy don't feel so good
tiny diamond you make the cutest Little
Flower Boy come on Daddy I'm the cutest
little flower man
really beloved we are gathered here
today
I'm John Dory branches long lost brother
what
food drama calling me
we were just listening to them
but that's all in the past
how come you never told never told me
you had a secret brother correction used
to be my brother
my brother's locked out on me and never
came back Branch we're out of sync we've
gone from Boys to Men and now there's
only one direction for us to go the back
streets Bridge it's time we find the
rest of our brothers and get the band
back together bro we're gonna have the
best family reunion ever Frozone 2.0
Frozone reunion froze on Here We Grow
Again Frozone where's they bro I don't
know we're gonna find them
[Music]
random dude on another Musical Adventure
oh hey tiny you see that button right
there oh you mean the button is taking
every fiber of my being not depressed
oh
[Music]
wow too much hustle is a thing
huh look at that
[Music]